qui est parfait mais
[Musique]
c'est le sens dans les carottes je vais
mourir sûrement
[Musique]
noël à tous j'ai toujours mis sont
[Applaudissements]
commis et six mois en tant driollet la
station service
on n'est pas les bons cambriolage s'est
amusé comme un fou
c'est aussi bien se pose est vieux plus
tôt
il ya juste une pomme de terre par
paires sont bien seuls pour chacun
quelqu'un a écouté un discours de la
réserve je me vois bien dans un bunker
personnellement rempli de conserves de
fayots et de bouffe pour chirac
pour les vies qu'on a partagé
pour nos magnifiques enfants pour nos
amis fidèles
que nous puissions reposer dans l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je dis juste qu'il faut être honnête
avec les enfants rien d'autre on sait
que les russes veulent tous nous tuer et
ils vont larguer des bombes de gaz
empoisonné demain matin c'est pas les
russes c'est la planète et nous en veut
à mort
saturent à tous qui sera encore vivants
à la surface de la terre
[Musique]
on leur a dit voter pour les verts
on veut vraiment être sûr que vous
comprenez bien ça nous les parents on
n'est pas responsable
je veux dire c'est encore moins de votre
faute
[Musique]
oh
ans
j'ai vu le film la route il n'est pas
question que je suive de cette façon là